the four fundamental forces of nature
gravity electromagnetism and the strong
and weak nuclear forces now scientists
have blasted neutrons through a crystal
of silicon
to create waves like waves crashing on
the beach helping physicists hunt for a
new fundamental force of nature a
so-called fifth force
[Music]
the force it binds the galaxy together
now physicists know that there may be
other forces in addition to gravity
electromagnetism and the nuclear forces
now if we were to observe a new force it
could answer the most fundamental
questions
ranging from the nature of dark matter
to the nature of dark energy
in 2021 an experiment carried out at
nist the national institute of standards
and technology gave some tantalizing
hints about a so-called fifth force
these researchers unlike the los alamos
lifetime measurements use neutrons to
bombard silicon crystals in order to set
a new constraint
on any potential fifth fundamental force
of nature that operates only at atomic
scales the study also included
measurements that are precisely
constraining about the structure of
silicon and how neutrons interact with
these crystals and how they behave on
their own
the study's lead author nist physicist
benjamin hicock
said the work of this fifth force search
is actually going on over an entire
length scale of human observation
ranging from the ultra small to large
even super human or super earth side he
says that physicists look for subtle
effects in everything from astronomical
surveys like galaxies to the minuscule
motions of custom-built microscopic
apparatus
so far all of these searches for fifth
fundamental forces have come up empty
renowned physicist eric adelberger of
the university of washington in seattle
who's not involved with the nist study
says that there's a reason to think
we're missing something
measuring the absolute value of
something as tricky always adelberger
and his own team are also looking for
the impact of fundamental new forces
concluded that the fifth force must be
so much weaker than some of the other
theories have predicted or it may not
even exist the nist experiment follows a
similar trajectory but it uses a
different experimental technique as the
leader benjamin hecox says the goal of
the experimentalist is to make strides
in limiting the strength of new forces
whatever the experiment can do for us it
happens to be on the atomic scale but
how do you measure the effects of
unknown interactions at microscopic and
submicroscopic scales it's extremely
challenging at the atomic realm you have
quantum effects that take over these
scales that they're probing are a
million times smaller
than the dot on the end of a sentence
how much matter can you get that still
behaves
according to a fifth force but doesn't
destroy the tenuous correlations between
these particles of silicon as they
interact with neutrons neutrons are
neutral so they can penetrate into these
crystals unlike say protons or electrons
the magnetic forces and fields of the
atomic nuclei of the silicon barely
perturb the neutrons as they penetrate
into these crystal lattices now neutrons
as we've discussed are not elementary
particles they're made up of clarks held
together glued together if you will by
gluons these gluons obey the strong
nuclear force strong interaction is
really a misnomer it should be called
the insanely strong reaction because
it's incredibly powerful and the quarks
that make up the neutron are almost
completely unmolested as they make their
way into these crystals because the
neutrons are on charge
electromagnetically they don't
participate in the electromagnetic
reaction to a very strong degree that
makes them ideal probes to shoot into
these crystals a co-author in the nisled
study by the name of albert young a
physicist at north carolina state
university he said at present at the
atomic length scales neutrons kind of
rule
in their experiment their collaborators
at the ryken center for advanced
photonics in japan made this very very
common material silicon it's one of the
most abundant elements in the entire
earth's crust but getting precision
machined silicon is very difficult to do
silicon is extremely hard and brittle
and it cracks
and to make it into a purified crystal
takes very advanced technology inside
this perfect crystal
where in the atoms of silicon are
perfectly isolated from sources of light
from heat from vibration external noise
the silicon atoms become arranged in a
perfect cityscape grid-like pattern as
these switzerland-like neutrons travel
through
unperturbed undisturbed and
non-interacting through the grid they
collide every so often with one of the
silicon atoms and they can evade others
but at the atomic scale the neutrons are
obeying the laws of quantum mechanics
and all these particles now exhibit
wave-like phenomena the silicon
collisions with the neutrons are similar
to waves crashing on a shore when a
neutron bumps into a silicon atom this
interaction creates a ripple the ripples
interact
and they overlap constructively here
destructively there and it makes a type
of pattern called a diffraction pattern
these brilliant researchers then ensured
that some of these crashing neutron
waves that lapped on the silicon shores
of atoms that they overlapped in a very
specific way so-called pandola song
oscillations i should get sabine
haasenfelder to pronounce this german
word these interference patterns are
kind of like the beats that you hear not
from beats headphones by dr dre but
actually interference patterns that you
hear from closely spaced speakers these
pandola song interference patterns have
been known about for a very long time
but they haven't really been used since
their discovery in the 1960s at mit most
experiments aren't sensitive to these
oscillations but the nist team was
they carefully analyzed the resulting
pattern of interference looking for
minuscule details about the scattering
silicon atoms that play the role in this
analogy of little tiny rocks and the
waves like the ocean waves in this
analogy are neutron quantum wave
function waves as they crash into them
they can tell how much energy the
amplitude of the wave that was carried
by each of these neutron incoming
crashing waves
they could also track do the rocks
themselves move in counter reaction to
the collision with these neutrons how
does this have anything to do with a
fifth force
well if there were a fifth force
interaction at play
the neutron wave interference pattern
would have manifested itself much the
same way that oceanographers here at san
diego's scripps institution of
oceanography use the pattern of waves on
the ocean's surface to reveal properties
deep deep below the surface on the ocean
floor
so they would have seen the
manifestation of a fifth force but they
didn't and actually they were able to
set a new constraint that's over an
order of magnitude better than previous
constraints on how massive a fifth force
of nature could be the nist team also
declares that a new improvement on their
innovative setup will allow them to make
even more strides in the precise
measurement of constraining ruling out
fifth forces this is another example of
something you hear about all the time on
this channel unlike searches for
wormholes and multiverses and maybe even
string theory itself we can learn as
much by ruling out theories as we can by
conjecturing new theories that can't be
tested so we learn a lot about the
properties of crystals about neutrons
and we actually rule out the behavior of
these fascinating fifth forces of nature
when researchers combine the neutron
lifetime measurements and other
properties such as the magnetic
properties of neutrons they'll learn
more about neutrons and they'll be able
to make more and more precise
constraints on so-called fifth forces
this is just one step
as researchers admit along a journey
that will hopefully illuminate some of
the most mysterious aspects of nature
is nature bountiful and plentiful
exhibiting more than just the four
familiar forces of nature we have yet to
see we know it's a tiny effect if it's
there at all the key is to not give up
and keep searching and who knows maybe
someone out there will play a role in a
novel new test of fundamental forces
fields and energy skills with
unbelievable cosmic implications what do
you think leave a comment below are
there more than four forces of nature
and if so what's the best way to look
for them don't forget to subscribe and
enjoy my mailing list at briankating.com
for bi-monthly updates on cool things
going on in the heavens and down here on
earth